Now this,
the baboon here who's supposed to be
basically just a fool.
When the story was first written,
he turned into what's essentially a
shaman across time and so he represents
the self from the union perspective.
Now the self is everything you could be
across time,
so imagine that there's you and there's
the potential inside you.
Whatever that is and potential is an
interesting idea because it's represents
something that isn't yet real.
Yet we act like it's real because people
will say to you,
you should live up to your potential and
that potential is partly what you could
be if you interacted with the world in a
manner that would gain you the most
information,
right?
Because you build yourself out of the
information in the piagetian sense,
but it's deeper than that too because we
know that if you take yourself and you
put yourself in a new environment,
new genes turned on in your nervous
system,
they encode for new proteins and so
you're full of biological potential.
That won't be realized unless you move
yourself around in the world into
different challenging circumstances and
that'll turn on different circuits.
So it's not merely that you're
incorporating information from the
outside world in the constructivist
sense,
it's that by exposing yourself to
different environments,
you put different physiological demands
on yourself all the way down to the
genetic level and that manifests new
elements of you.
And so one of the things that happens to
people,
and this is a very common cultural
notion,
is that you should go on a pilgrimage at
some point to somewhere central in that
would be say like the rock pride rock in
the lion king because you take yourself
out of your dopey little village and
that's just the little bounded you that
everyone knows and that isn't very
expanded.
And then you go somewhere dark and
dangerous to the central place and while
you do that,
you have adventures and they toughen you
and pull more out of you.
Like partly because you're becoming
informed,
which means information.
It means you're becoming more organized
at every level of analysis.
But there's also more of you too.
And so that's a very classic idea.
And then in in cathedrals in Europe,
especially at charter,
there's a big maze on the floor,
a circular maize,
which is a symbolic representation of
the pilgrimage for people who couldn't
do it.
And so it's a huge circle divided into
quadrants,
which is a union Mandela.
And you enter the maize at one point and
then you have to walk through the entire
maze north,
east,
west,
and south before you get to the center.
And the center is symbolized by a flower
that's carved in stone.
It looks like this.
It's big.
This maze,
hey,
it's large so that you can walk it.
And that's a symbolic pilgrimage.
It takes you to the center.
That's the center of the cross because
it's in a cathedral.
And that's the point of acceptance,
of voluntary suffering.
That's what that means.
And so you walk through,
you can call that a circum ambulation.
You go to all the corridors of the world
to find yourself.
And so while the self is,
is the baboon in this particular,
in this pr,
I think he's a mandrill actually in this
particular representation.
And he lives in the tree.
He lives in the tree of life.
It's a bail bab tree in this particular,
so the spirit that inhabits the tree of
life and he's the eternal wise man.
That's a way of thinking,
so is the king,
but he's.
He's sort of a superordinate king or an
outside king in some sense.
He's the repository of ancient wisdom
and the king is the manner in which that
wisdom is currently being acted out in
the world and so their friends,
and that means that the king is a good
king because if they,
if the king was a bad king,
he would be alienated from himself and
that would make him shallow and one
dimensional and that would make him a
bad ruler.
No union with the traditions of the
past.
To be a good ruler,
you have to rescue your father from the
underworld and integrate that,
and of course that's a main theme in
this entire movie.